you already know Super Bowl weekly and
AZ right now shout out to Def Jam shout
out to Remy Martin shout out to Jada
pink about to do what she does az's
finest baby let's get it
[Music]
I told that [__] wipe my shoe down you
step I don't fool around this [__]
claim she gangster but I ain't here let
off no full rounds Go full rounds like a
camera so but down my camera so so
please don't get it twisted cause I
twist you like a parent so uh my flow so
mean let's call Regina look in and scent
like Katie but your man get the Trina
that's why they look back at me they had
their backs at me now they pledge and
get down and hold it and they kept send
me begging from my attention busy making
Investments they too broke to pay
attention to my talking investing and
that's the real though goes out to all
specimen if I ever said I love you I
meant it you want special man cause I
don't let them in or do no cat fights
I'm a female dog with nine lives [__]
ask out that's right uh cause I am that
guy yeah should I say that girl shout
out to all my feminists and women around
the world anyways just moved to Georgia
where the peaches live next to Cali
wearing the beaches when you kick your
feet in kick the door and now both feet
and rap game take this beat in [__]
is my kids but never took their daddy
semen really gliding on this 808 on a
rocket
if I don't take this rap [__] down this
real estate really imma do that [__]
anyways in any state I'm in I conquer I
ain't talking commission I'm buying
flipping and getting commercials it's a
web like Parker I'm woke to the system
we in I wish they would try me Leanne
that's why my future bright they sleep
it's darker but they rather have
instructions how this ass shake when we
can exchange our knowledge and make this
whole world [__] shape oh God hey I
know you just watched a new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at a checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week